smiling jasmine very good
after 70 days three hours and 48 minutes
jasmine harrison arrived in antigua as a
record breaker
the youngest solo female to row 3 000
miles across the atlantic
it's up throwing 18 hours and
hardly sleeping i did it just as a
challenge after seeing
the finish line here in nelson stockyard
three years ago it just
happened to be that um i would
be the youngest i do that doesn't really
bother me world record all that
not a big sort of target just to do the
challenge
it wasn't all plain sailing jasmine's
boat capsized twice during the race
a frightening experience for her and her
family
when i'm the one hearing the news should
like phone me up
after and say i know she's fine at that
point
it's been worse for her going through it
so actually i'm hearing it
after the event so it's okay it's kind
of more wondering what's going to come
next
her supporters back home in thirsk had
little doubt that jasmine would
persevere
there's a certain element to standing
next to your pal pulling a pint being
like
oh so you're going to roll the ocean
yeah yeah it's just something to do with
it and you're like
all right jazz no worries and then the
more she spoke about it the more
you could see the passion in her you
could see she'd speak to everyone about
it everyone was so invested in her
it just became so apparent that this is
jasmine's life goal this is what's going
to happen and everybody knew that
francis davis is one of the few people
who can understand what jasmine has been
through
five years ago she was part of the
yorkshire rose team that became the
oldest all-female crew
to complete the challenge and she was
glad of the company
we had each other to rely on we had each
other to talk to whenever we had a low
moment there was always someone in the
boat with a high moment so
someone to talk to someone to share the
experience with i cannot imagine i don't
think i could have done it on my own
i wouldn't have done it on my own i'd
only do it with some friends
to put jasmine's feet into perspective
more people have climbed everest than
have ever rode an ocean
it clearly takes a special kind of
person to do it at all
to do it solo and at the age of just 21
is truly remarkable fraser moored sky
news
first